my name is pearl wolfe and i am the lead
singer songwriter for the band peril and
we are an all girl hasidic rock band
from crown heights brooklyn
all of our live concerts are for women
only
i grew up in a hasidic home
so
having a separation of the sexes in
certain places is pretty common
there's a law and judaism for men
not to listen to the singing voice of a
woman who is not an immediate family
member
i would say one of the biggest
misconceptions that people have about
the hasidic community people think that
women are totally oppressed that women
can't be leaders i felt very much
empowered as a woman spending time with
other powerful women and
having time to connect and having our
own space women deserve a space to rock
out
the response from the hasidic community
has been really positive mostly
you know let's let's empower women let's
make something new for women
when fans come over and tell you
i felt so comfortable tonight i felt
like i could dance i felt like i could
be myself or i really felt a powerful
energy being around other women i'm like
okay we're doing something important and
that's really all that matters
you